hello everyone i'm ken shak and today
i'm gonna speak uh about real-time
personalization with that tickets wi-fi
uh the talk is mostly gonna focus so
i'll start off by you know giving you a
brief overview of what spotify is all
about
i'll give you a brief introduction about
monetization
product
uh and spotify
and then i'll dive deep into one of the
use cases that we're trying to solve uh
using real-time personalization
to optimize user experience
in on our platform
so before i begin let me introduce
myself briefly
i've been at spotify since 2011 and i
tend to focus
mostly on data and backend engineering
problems uh working with the
monetization team here
and
recently i've been focusing a lot on
targeting infrastructure and uh the the
ads personalization piece and you know
mainly
the real-time aspects of it because
that's really interesting
so since you guys are here i'm assuming
you know what spotify is for those of
you who don't know what spotify is uh we
are a digital music streaming company
we started in 2006 and as of today we
are available in 56 markets
which is 56 countries
we have a catalog of over 20 million
songs
and
we it's not a static catalog we almost
add 20 000 songs daily to that catalog
so it's an ever increasing size of
catalog
we have over 24 million users uh those
are active users not just registered
users uh
and of those 24 billion users about 6
million users over 6 million users are
paying subscribers
we also have very
highly engaged user base and those users
have created over a billion and a half
playlists on a platform
so let me start by giving you a high
level overview of
the monetization strategy of product and
spotify
at spotify we don't not only generate a
lot of revenue uh
through you know a freemium model and
that model is basically uh
a two-tier you know
a business model we have a free uh
uh music streaming tier where basically
the ads
pay for all the music that gets consumed
and then there's a premium tier where
the users appear you know fixed monthly
fee to access our service with uh you
know ads free experience at the same
time they also get some premium features
like spotify connect which is sort of
like uh airplay and then you know there
are things like offline music access and
so on and so forth
so through our monetization strategy we
have not only generated a lot of revenue
but as of today we've paid over a
billion dollars back back to the rights
holders of music
uh
in our user base one out of every four
user is
used as a ping subscriber which means
about 75 of our users
are using the free tier and they see
you know ads on
their clients
uh
in addition to these things
based on our uh you know
strategy we also see our platform uh as
you know uh
as a platform which will help artists uh
and music labels promote their content
so it's not only a platform for
delivering ads but it's also the
platform for delivering album promotions
and bunch of other interesting ads which
i'll talk about later in my talk
so what's what's our mission uh
the overarching mission that we're
working towards is to power the free
tier with ads that the customers love uh
and practically this translates into two
you know submissions or goals uh one of
them is selecting users brands and
artists with standard promotional
experiences
and secondly delivering the right kind
of ad messages to users at all time
if you notice uh in the first
submission or sort of like the goal
we focus on giving the best experience
not only to the brands for sending
across their message but also making
sure that the user every users are
really engaged and they are delighted by
the promotional experiences at the same
time artists and music cables can
promote their content and we
use and make make the most of our
advertisement platform
so to actually uh you know work towards
this mission we realize we need to
introduce new ad formats uh which
abide by these four you know guiding
principles uh the first of them is we
should have native ads what that means
is our app content should look uh very
native with the platform which would
feel like any other content it shouldn't
have a genuine experience for our users
secondly our ads need to be actionable
so users should be able to do things
with their ads they should be able to
follow a playlist or click an ad or
try and skip an ad and then do bunch of
things which makes them
more involved with the
messaging at the same time we want to
ensure that we don't get very
complicated ads so that they cannot
scale so ads need to be scalable and
lastly and then one of the most
important things that we focus on is to
make sure that our ads are engaging so
once users are shown an ad they should
be able to do things with it so for
instance if it's a video app they should
be able to rotate the screen
uh and then watch you know
in different aspect ratio or they should
be able to play
music right away when they see an even
promotion
so let me give you some examples
of few ad formats that we've
experimented with and and some of these
are live today
this one is called spotlight uh this ad
format gets used by uh
the label relations team that we have
here who work closely with music labels
and they're using this ad format
for helping users discover new kind of
music and new content
so if you think about those four
principles i talked about
you can see that this ad format is very
native it doesn't feel like an ad it
almost feels like any other content on a
platform
it's also very actionable so right right
there in the ad you can follow that
playlist you can literally start
streaming music by hitting the play
button
it's scalable because the specifications
of these uh this particular ad is very
simple
complete for it and it's not very
difficult to generate this content
and lastly it's engaging because user
can actually consume music
by you know taking some action on this
app so they really uh
feel engaged with this uh this kind of
ad format and in future if we show new
ads in the same format they've probably
you know taken action on it as well
uh something similar but but not quite
is uh what we call admin promotion
uh this is you know an album promotion
for
a
new album uh from an artist so this is a
way of actually promoting their content
so we want to see we want to make sure
that the artists and music labels
you know also get an opportunity to use
our ad platform for promoting their
content and deliver their message
this is another format which we call
sponsored genre and it's sort of solves
a different use case so the first two
ads were towards uh you know music
tables this one is stated towards
brands so here there's a genre uh
a browse page which is called happiness
and it's been sponsored by coca-cola
it's one of our premium partners
and
if you look at it you know coca-cola
wants to be associated with this mood of
happiness and wants to be engaged or
rather have
have an audience who's engaged with the
content of the platform
so we've used this format uh to make
sure that the ads are not jarring and
they're not too loud and at the same
time
the brand can interact with the audience
and
measure
the engagement through a bunch of
actions that they can take on this app
for instance if they start streaming a
lot of content a lot of tracks from this
playlist we know that they sort of
associate coca-cola brand with happiness
more
so this sort of solves the first mission
that i talked about which was making
sure that
our
users friends and artists are actually
delighted with the experiences
but if all these app formats are not
necessarily delivered at the right time
then we can create uh hell
as you can see
in all these uh
you know
uh messages that our users sent us we
definitely don't have a very happy
audience
during the christmas of 2012
a lot of our users complained that we
were delivering them inappropriate ads
when they were in a session
uh listening to christmas music with the
kids around them
and this was definitely not
uh
you know the right message for the right
moment for that particular moment
so
uh this was definitely a problem that we
had in our platform because you know as
a
sort of uh optimization or relevancy was
not one of the high priorities for us
back in the day because we're still
growing our business and uh we didn't
have such a big
free user base most of our users were
still premium users so now it's been a
new focus for our for our company to
make sure that we fix these kind of
problems
and
that's where the you know the
interesting challenging problems lie
so when we saw that we had these kind of
problems we went back to the drawing
board and i tried to figure out what are
the things that we need to do to solve
uh for that specific uh use case of the
right message for every moment
the few things that we came up with were
making sure that our ads are context
aware what that means is making sure
that we know um what's the context of a
session that the user is in what are the
kind of music that they're streaming
what are the kind of actions that
they're taking on their hands
uh what's what's the view in the clan
that they're focusing on
based on these kind of things we get
very strong signals to make sure that we
deliver the right kind of ads to them so
if we know for instance uh that a user
is actually streaming kids music we
definitely don't want to send them
inappropriate ads that we did in the
past
uh
in addition to this we also want to make
sure that we measure glad formats so the
ad formats that we saw in
the previous
slides
they have a lot of actions built in and
we can measure those actions and those
give us strong signals about whether
users are having a positive response to
the ads or they're trying to avoid the
ads
by using these measurements we can
optimize the ad experience understand
the relevancy of ads to certain kind of
all kinds of users
and then figure out you know what class
of ads are more relevant to certain
users
but on the other side we also want to
make sure that our brands actually
understand their audience very well so
we wanted to build tools
uh so that the brands can really
understand what are the kind of um
you know
what are the features of audience that
feel engaged with their messaging
for instance demographics is a very
simple one but also things like um for
instance red bull would want to figure
out
what's the genre of music that the
sports lover uh scream uh and then based
on that they would wanna target those
kind of ads to uh
that specific audience
so now that we
in future you know build like these
tools um so that the brands can
understand their audience we also want
to make sure that our targeting
infrastructure is really really flexible
because
as the um
understand their audience well they want
to use the more branded targeting to
reach to their audiences
so having a targeted infrastructure
which can incorporate new ways of
targeting users
really helps and lastly we want to make
sure that we analyze the user behavior
on our platform
to improve that relevancy uh and an
example of that is if a user is actually
streaming classical music and at that
point in time we send a very jarring
loud app to a user that would ruin their
whole music experience
so we want to make sure that in real
time and also in batch mode
we try and understand the musical
profile of a user and use that to deal
with the ads experience
in all of this we also had an important
learning
uh that a lot of these things need to
happen in real time
and the reason for that is
it's only in real time that we can truly
assess the context of a user like you
know the current view in the client or
the last track which was screen
uh it's only in real time that we can
actually get an immediate feedback
uh about you know whether an ad busted
by user or not whether a user actually
followed the playlist and use those kind
of
signals to
optimize the ad delivery in real time
at times using batch data for
understanding musical profiles is really
useful
but you can't really act
on signals that you're getting in real
time
based on that kind of analysis so we do
uh
we definitely do a lot of batch analysis
and generate uh you know the user
profiles but the real-time aspect of it
is really the
crux of it and really crucial
and lastly uh by making sure that we
have an infrastructure where we can
make decisions in real time
we actually increase a lot of ad
opportunities uh the canonical example
is you know hyper local targeting uh
where a user is probably walking past
starbucks store and we can actually show
user
an ad to redeem an offer
we can also you know use some of the
mood data from the metadata that we have
about tracks to figure out what's the
mood of the user and make sure that we
can target ads
based on that there are a bunch of other
examples for
uh you know doing something similar like
weather and such
so using these learnings we went back
to try and figure out
how do we actually then solve the
problem of serving white message for
every moment
and the two basic themes that came up
were we need to fix uh you know the ads
bad ads or inappropriate ads problem in
the music context
and for that we have to do a real-time
analysis of like the short window of
user activity
uh which involves
uh and then i'll go
and talk about
some of the details of that in
some of the slides uh after this
so using some of the open source
technologies you want to solve that
problem and then there's a problem of
improving the ad relevancy based on the
user behavior which involves basically
building user profiles in real time and
updating those profiles in real time but
also doing a batch analysis uh of the
longer window of user activity to
generate the the profile for user uh for
their musical place for their uh you
know ads behavior and what kind of
ad verticals are they more responsive to
uh so since you know these two themes
have a lot of specific problems we
wanted to solve for some quick wins and
then iterate over those things in the
future
one of the first problems that we saw a
lot of complaints about was
that the problem of not having you know
ads um
uh or inappropriate ads when the kids
music is being streamed so we wanted to
solve that problem
and you also wanted to fix the relevancy
of ads in the music context that's
another problem that we've seen and
users have complained about that where
some of our ads are really loud uh when
users are streaming let's see classical
music or
you know some jazz music and that's not
necessarily appropriate for that session
and both of those things could be
solved in
real time and match mode
so this is like a very simplistic view
of our targeting architecture
where
the client whenever there's an ad break
and if for those who don't know
uh we have clients on desktop mobile
devices and on browser which is a web
client so whenever there's an ad break
you know it
makes a request of the targeting service
to get the context uh about what's
what's the user's uh context for that
moment
uh
and then once the targeting service
returns that context a client sends that
information to an ad server
uh the ad server you know uh runs its
google engine tries to figure out the
most appropriate app for that momentum
delivers it after the client
uh the targeting service
in a very simplistic uh manner uh which
has been represented here talks to bunch
of data stores and the two key ones are
the user registration data store which
has like standard data about demographic
information of the users that they give
up when they're registering our service
and then there's a more interesting
piece which i'm going to dive deep into
which is the user activity store this is
where we maintain the user profiles uh
and store the information about the
current genre the current
mood and a bunch of other activities
in real time and some of that activity
is also computed in batch mode like the
least profile of a user based on the
musical
you know consumption history
so having understood the interaction
between the client and the targeting
backend
we wanted to make sure that we complete
the feedback loop and collect as much
information and signals as possible in
real time
so uh we
we have our clients which generate a lot
of a lot of log information and
the information that they basically
captured is
the
any kind of response to ads any kind of
you know movement um
based on the views on the client
and and the kind of things that have
been streamed the kind of
uh apps within our client which get
loaded
all that gets uh locked
and then we wanted a stable log
collection framework to collect all that
logs
we wanted a log processing system which
could process those logs so basically we
need to filter out the messages which
are not important do some aggregation to
generate user profiles and then
eventually store that in a storage
system
a fast storage system which can actually
be looked up during certain time by the
targeting service to get the context
and to make some of the decisions about
how to fill those boxes
for log collection log processing and
storage i'm going to talk about some of
the
uh the requirements that we have for
those systems
so we wanted our log collection
system to be scalable
which meant um
it needs to collect log messages from
you know terabytes of data that gets
generated uh let's get into the numbers
in the next slide so we generate a lot
of data in our service services so
there's a lot of service locked data
there's a lot of user activity data
and we need to collect all that data in
a scalable fashion in a reliable fashion
with low latency
we also need capability to process those
logs in batch in real time mode and have
a facility to you know filter out the
messages aggregate
and then basically generate user profile
and we definitely want a storage system
which has fast needs
so that we can enable certain time
lookups and do updates to that user
store in real time
uh so these are some of the numbers uh
you know um
based on
uh
the the data that gets generated in our
cluster so
spotify has been uh using halo for a
long time if you see
a guy in the picture this that picture
is from he's one of our engineers that
picture is from 2008 that's our
uh second generation hadoop cluster back
in the days which which got overheated
uh since then we've definitely you know
improved a lot uh right now we have a
seven hundred node cluster in london
and it's probably one of the bigger
uh hadoop clusters in europe
uh we generate you know four gigabytes
of service logs daily uh
uh we have 4.5 terabytes of uncompressed
user data which gets generated daily
and
then the processed data which which gets
generated out of hadoop jobs is about 64
terabytes
and we use a bunch of technologies for
processing all these data so we have a
yarn supported mapreduce
uh we have a patchy giraffe being used
by some of the teams from
graph processing we use apache storm for
real-time processing and that's one of
the tools that we use for this use case
i'll get into the details of that in a
bit
there are a few teams who are
experimenting with the patchy spark for
some of the
new real-time use cases as well
so based on the choices that we have
internally
some of that is also you know the open
source technologies and some of that is
in-house
we figured that
to fill those blocks uh we are going to
use kafka for log collection we are
going to use either hadoop or storm for
log processing and storage we are going
to use cassandra memcached
so getting specifically into log
collection company-wide uh you know
there's a team who actually works on
data infrastructure we they experimented
with both blue and kafka
for
that specific use case
with kafka and that's why we ended up
choosing kafka for those who don't know
what kafka is uh it's a
you know distributed pubs up kind of uh
system used for high throughput use used
for high throughput applications uh such
as you know log block collection and
long delivery and we use that in our use
case
for log processing in batch mode we use
hadoop quite a lot and for real-time use
cases apache storm
is being used quite a lot
apache storm is a relatively new
technology it's been open sourced uh it
was developed in open source by twitter
it's it's
been out there for about two years now
year and a half to two years and it's
spotify we've been using it for about
seven to eight months
and for a lot of storage we end up using
cassandra and bim cash internally for
this specific use case uh of real time
has targeting we ended up using memcache
because we didn't care so much about
persistence and
uh most of our data even if it gets lost
it's okay
and the reads and the rights were really
quick so that's what worked out best for
our specific use case
so for those who don't know a lot about
storm um
uh
in layman's term it's uh you know like
without the hdfs it's a real time screen
processing framework
it's like mapreduce uh but you know with
many reducer steps it's fault tolerant
and it gives you you know guaranteed
message processing
we've been using storm for about seven
to eight months now it's been used by a
bunch of uh teams for different
applications we use it for ads the
recommendation team uses analytics and
monitoring to use it
we have a decent size cluster not too
big it's still sort of an experimental
mode but we are using it for a lot of
production
uh level stuff as well
uh
and to give you some
quick summary of what storm does
uh
storm basically as i said it's a you
know
stream processing framework uh there are
two concepts primary concepts installed
uh
one of them is called the spout
which is a source of the message stream
and another one is called the bolt which
is like a processing unit for
consuming and processing missing streams
and you know doing certain kind of
computations
this whole wiring of spouts and bolts is
called the topology and you can wire
them in any fashion so you can see that
an input of a spout can go to multiple
poles
and uh you know multiple poles can send
their output as input to another bolt
bolts can do any kind of operation they
can do filtration aggregation and uh
since um
uh storm guarantees uh you know it's
very fault alright and it guarantees uh
sort of uh
let me go over to that again you know
it's fault tolerant and it
guarantees message processing in most
cases you know any message that you get
ends up being processed
and if some of the you know the workers
die it restarts and takes care of a
bunch of things so it really works well
for this specific use case
so the use case that i'm going to talk
about is using real-time session genre
information to control adsense in real
time and we are going to use star
for processing all the log messages that
we get in real time
generate the the profile of users
based on the genre
that they're streaming
and then use that in the targeting
backend to give the context back to the
client so that it can fetch the right
hand from that server so this is how the
flow of things is going to be
so kafka is going to
collect the logs send it to storm
uh storm is going to filter out certain
messages aggregate certain kind of
messages at the user level
so all that user profile information in
memcache which gets spread by targeting
banking
and uh this is almost real-time system
so that's why it's a software system and
it's really easy to scale so this is how
the flow of things is going to be
so getting into the the interesting part
of how we actually access the data
uh all the clients that spotify they
talk to a gateway service which we call
access point
uh
and access point generates
or rather
access points have kafka producers
installed
and they
transmit all the client related lock
messages to
kafka directly
other services do something similar but
any kind of log message or signal that
gets generated in the client comes from
access point
and we have
this system in all our data centers so
we have
kafka producers and all the data centers
what they do is
they send message to the kafka broker
which eventually sends uh all the
messages to the big kafka cluster that
we have in london
data center
and we have a consumer which consumes
these messages from
uh kafka broker
and uh sends it to um
a hadoop cluster and writes it to hdfs
and some of that and those messages
messages also get string to the strong
cluster
once we have the messages uh being
stripped of the storm storm cluster
we have a kafka spout which is basically
the source of the message streams
uh which starts emitting uh
you know the uh the messages that we
that you've subscribed on
uh are subscribed to
to the boards in this topology this is
how our gender topology looks like
so
uh for this specific example the log
message that we're interested in is
called end song which basically tells
you
uh all the all the details about
when a track was screened
so we are subscribing to nsung message
in kafka
kafka starts uh streaming those messages
uh and emits the uh the doubles to end
some filter bolt
the enzyme filter bolt is a simple bolt
which um basically just extracts the
user and with the tracking
from that message and filters out uh you
know some of the some of the log
messages uh for things like if you know
the track was streamed for less than
certain amount of time
and if the track was not streamed from
the spotify server if it was a local
track and few other things
after the filtration process it emits
the tuple of user id and track id to the
metadata bolt
uh what this bolt does is it talks to
one of the interior stores
does a lookup based on the track id uh
and gets the genre information so at the
the at the end of that process the
metadata bolt is emitting
uh
a user id along with the genre
so
the message has been translated from a
user id and track id to user again a
genre uh in user genre board we're doing
aggregation and we we have like
a special in-house least frequency uh
used you know
uh cache
built in that specific board which
figures out which is like the top genre
for the user in that session it
completes the the weights based on the
moving window of the tracks that have
been streamed in their respective genre
and once we've figured out the top genre
for users every once in a while we emit
that to a memcache board which is
literally an interface to memcache so
all it does is it gets a user id and
their genre and emits that to a memcache
which is that user genre store so in the
earlier diagram where i showed the
targeting
service talking to user activity store
one of those activities is the genre and
that's where the information gets stored
so for this specific use case
this is how we solve
the problem of
figuring out the genre in the session
and using that as a terminology value
parameter uh in real time
so having built this one of the
important things was measuring the
effectiveness of this new feature
uh the way we do that
is
we build a lot of ad quality scores from
lower level metrics like the number of
clicks obviously um
and things like you know if someone
followed a playlist which was shown in
an album promotion
or someone tried to skip an ad
or someone trying to do something which
is more direct but then you also have
downstream metrics like uh
any ad
did that affect the number of streams
that the user
actually had for a particular kind of
music
uh so the downstream effects is
overall engagement of the user so the
user starts using a platform less than
what the user did before consuming
certain kind of ads
uh that's
a strong signal in addition to that
things like uh
uh the number of streams for that
particular album which are shown in an
algorithm promotion it's it's an it's a
strong signal
in addition to these you know uh signals
there are other kind of things um
which which we take into account and
then try and figure out you know
classify things as positive responses or
the things that user did to avoid an ad
so once we have built this quality score
then we use that uh to validate certain
uh you know hypothesis that we have for
example like do mid-roll ads perform
better than pre-roll video ads and
design those experiments and evaluate
them against those quality scores
and we also want to make sure lastly
that we can actually some of these
optimizations in real time
uh to uh you know improve the delivery
of ads for instance if you find that the
user is actually
uh
you know trying to avoid a lot of ads in
real time we can
make sure that the next app that gets
delivered to the user is
slightly different
so based on these things we measure the
effectiveness and overall we found that
a lot of our advertisers are really
interested in these kind of targeting
features
and users have you know you've seen
slight improvement in in the way the
users respond to these kind of ads
uh
so this is how like we've solved for one
very specific use case and then there
are a bunch of other interesting use
cases that we're working on
uh overall at spotify
the ads mission of the monetization
mission has been like a recent mission
and we're trying to solve our
challenging problems one of them is
improving that relevancy
uh some of the problems are you know
trying to build segments of audiences uh
target against
and so on and so forth so if you really
like any of these problems that we're
gonna work on on those do check out our
jobs page or you know reach out to me or
lindsey
after this
so that's it i want to open it up for q
and a round
any questions
to use any data from outside of
spotify interactions to do ad
optimization or anything like that so as
of today we don't uh but
sure so the question was do we use any
third party data to improve the ads
optimization within spotify so as of
today we don't
but uh we recently acquired a company
called economist which does a lot of
music intelligence and they have a lot
of data from the web they the mind the
you know they scrape the web and in mind
out of that data so potentially we can
start using some of that going forward
since they're part of spotify now but we
are not actively using anything
from third-party sources
any more questions
sure uh you said you're able to optimize
delivery of the ads based on these
different criteria that you listed
um now your ad server is efp
it's partly dfbb we're doing the
transition but for most of these
problems we're using dfp
okay and you're able to
have dfp
uh get that logic within the fee maybe
you just talked to that a little bit or
is that through their apis
some of the things is uh you know we can
you know blacklist certain kind of ads
based on it's a trafficking thing so for
instance we know that certain kind of
ads if we don't want to you know show
those ads for instance if the genre of a
user in that session is a kid's music so
using some of those techniques you can
really avoid serving those kind of ads
so
you know some of those problems can be
solved by trafficking but you want to
make sure that you send the right kind
of key value parameters
in the add call to our dfp
any more questions
cool thanks
you